hello and welcome to this video what it
gasps holy gasps hmm
yeah usually could avoid the moment I
wonder if I should do that he's playing
the Berlin right
okay let's try I just want to play a
speedy game here and see if he can what
he does he's playing on time I know I
lost a bit of time with mopes check with
the first couple of moves thinking about
if I go here for or not but I'm just
playing this extremely solid line
I know this is the kind of stuff that
she likes to play but I just want to
want to see if I can do okay on this
home tour so to say there's not much
going on
maybe we'll create you what make sense
make sense
check you're not much going on so I'm
slightly ahead on the clock this is one
of those games that will last forever I
don't want to go to e3 him
I wonder what after 4 maybe let's do
that I mean I'm beating he fathered how
bad can it be gaining some space here so
not much going on
[Music]
[Music]
really why is that any good I take and
go a4 strange it's probably a draw but
anybody anybody I am better
just kind of irritated here so I stay
away yeah I cannot play for win yeah
yeah a five it's never really going to
work but if I go around probably stood
as a draw I'm aiming
just kind of unsure if I maybe you still
can do something so there are our third
game drum roll
yeah well it's it's seven points I know
it's it's hit stamp boring but anyway I
just want to sometimes like play this
game and see what happens I mean he he
often out placed me from those endings
and sometimes I just say okay let's
let's play one of those and see if I can
hold it it's still kind of weird I was I
was really surprised that he went into
this but it is probably just a draw yeah
there's this kinghorn ending mm maybe
before I mean here if anybody wider
slightly better because I have more
space and I have those have this
reserved move but probably Prodi it is a
drum before also should be a draw I can
never really enter so I was trying to
play for the outside passer this one but
there's just no way for me to to really
make this pass account
[Music]
do tell it's not I mean it is a draw
yeah I'm very very sure but yeah
computer it's probably deep enough here
to see something is there some hidden
there's some hidden resource that I'm
not seeing I don't think there is it was
just a draw okay guys thanks for
watching